bonjour mon avis dès aujourd'hui et jean
marc jancovici bonjour monsieur jean
gaumy si vous êtes un spécialiste des
questions énergétiques et du climat
shift project et puis aussi carbone 4
vous êtes associé alors nous sommes à
quelques mois de la coop 26 qui aura
lieu en angleterre quels sont les
annonces clé que l'on peut attendre et
quels sont les jeux d'influencé que vous
percevez à l'aube de cette comme 26 ans
pendant longtemps j'ai péché par excès
de naïveté en pensant que les kops
étaient comme des structures
décisionnelles dont on a l'habitude
il ya un chef et ensuite des gens qui
exécute les décisions du chef en
espérant que les décisions du chef soit
sage et puis il m'a fallu un certain
temps pour comprendre en fait la coop
n'a pas de chef
en fait elle ne décide de rien elle
entérine la coop comme toutes les
assemblées onusienne
c'est un endroit où tout se décide par
consensus et un parallèle que je prends
souvent c'est la coop c'est un peu comme
une assemblée de copropriétaires
donc vous imaginez 200 copropriétaires
dans une propriété qui doivent décider à
l'unanimité d'un programme de travaux où
chaque copropriétaire a une voix quelle
que soit la surface de son appartement
par contre les charges sont au prorata
des surfaces
le programme des travaux n'est pas
décidée avant que les copropriétaires
commencé à délibérer il n'y a pas de
syndic
il n'y a pas de projet de résolution et
ils doivent se mettre à l'huile d'accord
à l'unanimité sur un programme de
travaux voilà quelle est la probabilité
contraignant évidemment qui va leur
coûter très cher donc l'immeuble plus de
riz de s'effondrer que les hommes en
voilà donc probabilité qu'ils y arrivent
0 et en fait c'est exactement ce qui se
passe dans la coop la coop n'a pas de
chef et la secrétaire qui entérine mais
elle n'a personne qui propose le
président de la coop en fait il est
juste là pour donner la parole mais il
n'est pas là pour proposer des
résolutions enfin pas formellement en
tout cas et comme tout se décide par
consensus magnifique et un pays qui
bloque et puis le consensus n'a pas lieu
donc en fait tout se calme sur le plus
petit dénominateur commun est en fait le
plus petit dénominateur commun c'est ce
que les gens sont déjà prêts à faire
donc en fait la coop ne change rien par
rapport au destin du monde c'est
ailleurs que les choses se passent
ça donne l'occasion d'en parler donc
j'ai envie de dire que ça le principal
bénéfice de la fère et médiatique
par contre ça ne s'éteindront d'ici là
est-ce que alors par quel miracle ça
fonctionnait en décembre 2015 par quel
miracle parce que ce que vous dites
finalement sur la coop c'est ce que l'on
peut dire sur la communauté
internationale tout le monde en parle
personne n'a jamais vu c'est comme le
monstre du loch ness et donc par quel
miracle en 2015 on est parvenus à un
accord alors dont le caractère
contraignant est sujet à caution bien au
mains cet accord de tous ses
copropriétaires y compris les squatteurs
qui normalement dans un beau chapitre
alors en fait le vrai enfin l'accord le
plus structurant il n'a pas du tout eu
lieu à paris en 2015 il a eu lieu à
copenhague en 2009
en 2009 on s'y dit pourtant comme un
échec y compris par barack obama
absolument alors c'est un gt - en
l'occurrence aspirations donc c'est la
première fois que c'est pour ça que
c'était un succès évidemment c'est la
première fois que j'ai vu l'histoire se
faire et en fait j'ai vu la formation du
mot échec
je peux vous raconter l'anecdote si sa
venue exercer au début de la négociation
en fait vous avez un gros document dans
lequel chaque pays mais ce qu'ils
aimeraient y trouver et à chaque fois
que deux pays ou plus sont pas d'accord
entre eux les expressions sont mis entre
crochets alors à l'entrée de la coop de
copenhague il ya quelques milliers je
crois d'expression entre crochets dans
le texte qui est soumis à la discussion
a commencé par l'élévation de
température maximale sur laquelle les
pays s'accordent et je me rappelle que
le texte commence par attendu que
ceux-ci se lâcher pas quoi les pays
décident de limiter à un abus de 50
reprocher de entre crochets 2,5 entre
crochets 3 entre crochets être observées
jusqu'à quatre et demi je crois comme ça
et tout le reste est à l'avenant
bon donc les gens commencent à essayer
de se mettre d'accord chacun sur un
petit bout du texte au bout d'une
semaine ça patauge arrivent les
ministres ça patauge toujours à une des
présidents il ya toujours rien signé
bon vous savez comme moi que un
président ça vient pas pour discuter le
bout de gras c'est bien pour signer le
truc qui a déjà voilà c'est fait pour la
photo est signée de taux qui a été
négocié et alors là il y a
deux ou trois présidents dont sarkozy
parce que je crois que fin mai mais mes
informateurs interne me disent qu'il a
joué un rôle significatif là dedans qui
disent on peut pas repartir la queue
basse comme ça faut qu'on fasse quelque
chose donc il ya une espèce de nuit des
longs couteaux dans la nuit du jeudi au
vendredi de la deuxième semaine où il ya
27 chefs d'état qui sont réunis dans une
pièce il ya brice lalonde qui était donc
c'est lui qui m'a raconté comment ça
s'est passé
et puis ils commencent à se mettre
d'accord en disant bon alors rien 2° 3°
3 3 n'est pas d'accord à l'époque de
derrick fille et ils font ce que font
des chefs d'état réunis dans une pièce
pendant la nuit c'est à dire qu'ils font
tous les postes avec 12 ce truc sur
lequel ils sont d'accord et en fait tout
ce qui est structurant dans l'accord de
paris a été décidée à copenhague cette
nuit là et ça a été une op à du g20 sur
les nations unies c'est ça qui s'est
passé en pratique cette nuit là mais
c'était un processus qui n'avait plus
rien à voir avec le processus onusien et
en particulier les ong qui pouvait
regarder tout ce qui se passait et il se
trouve que par ailleurs pour des raisons
logistiques
les ong avaient toutes été éjecté du
centre de conférence parce que les
danois avaient vu un peu juste à poznan
l'année précédente où j'étais aussi il y
avait eu 13 mille personnes donc les
danois avait du bon et on va caler sur
15000 manque de pot la deuxième semaine
avec toutes les délégations
présidentielle règne de celle d'obama y
avait 200 personnes je crois une fois
que vous mettiez les délégations
présidentielle 5000 personnes la presse
5000 personnes plus les ministres et
c'est encore 5000 personnes les ong qui
la première semaine avait 5000
représentants dans l'enceinte
la semaine d'après on utilise donc les
90 qui était encore dans l'enceinte
était chauffée à blanc j'étais furax
comme pas possible
et au moment où fuite le draft de
l'accord que les présidents étaient en
train de signer l'objet ils font les
brouillons ils entament ce n'est pas le
bon bout de foot à la corbette cela et
je me rappelle comme si j'étais hier
c'était vendredi à 3h du matin j'étais
en train de discuter avec la femme qui
s'occupait du desk de la fp à copenhague
tout le monde se tourner les pouces et
enfin tous les gens qui n'est pas dans
la salle se tourner les pouces les
fonctionnaires pouvait rien dire puisque
les présidents étaient en train de
discuter
la presse n'avait rien à dire qu'ils
étaient les seuls qui pouvaient dire
quelque chose c'était le représentant
des ong est arrivée une jeune femme du
vvf tenant à draft de deux pages elle le
pose
sur le bureau de dan chaon que je me
rappelle encore c'était elle et elle lui
dit regardez moi ça c'est un scandale de
pages c'est un échec et le mot est parti
de là donc je me rappelle très j'ai vu
l'histoire pour une fois ce n'était pas
du tout un échec
en fait c'était un vrai succès parce
qu'on s'était enfin mis d'accord sur
deux degrés et on aurait dit que c'était
un succès peut-être que la face de
l'histoire aurait été un tout petit peu
changé
en attendant si on revient la physique
ce qu'on peut constater c'est que le
rythme d'augmentation du co2 dans l'air
avant les coop et après les cop est
exactement le même
avant copenhague et après copenhague est
exactement le même et avant paris et
après paris est exactement le même
donc si on juge du succès de la main
d'oeuvre au fait que ça change le monde
physique derrière pour le moment aucune
coop n'a été un succès il ya en plus des
objectifs très ambitieux qui sont mis
pour 2050 et pour 2030 - guise us cas
pas aussi une tentation des différents
leaders politiques de porter leurs
ambitions sur leurs successeurs et non
pas sur les efforts qu'ils ont faits
revers est ce que l'un des problèmes
majeurs et chant climatique c'est que ce
sont les générations futures qui vont
payer et que quand vous êtes élu vous
pensez plutôt le taux de croissance de
l'an prochain que retour de
réchauffement climatique dans 20 ans
voilà aussi je vais pas vous apprendre
ce métier dans l'est dans les structures
politiques avec des échéances courtes
donc typiquement les démocraties avec
remise en jeu du mandat quelques
quelques années tout effort
maintenant pour un résultat plus tard et
toujours quelque chose de très très
délicat à mettre en oeuvre
donc là en ce qui concerne le climat on
est typiquement dans ce genre de cas de
figure c'est à dire qu'il faut faire
l'effort maintenant pour le bénéfice
plus tard c'est un peu comme la mise au
régime
c'est désagréable tout de suite pour un
bénéfice qui arrivera plus tard que
ventre le continuer à trop manger tout
de suite ou pas ça ça change pas grand
chose dans les trois semaines qui
viennent après que le bénéfice a lieu
voilà on exactement c'est que c'est
votre propre record alors que l'offre
sera d'autre vivre simplement
alors ce même pas parce que en fait ce
qu'il ya quelque chose qu'il faut avoir
en tête c'est que la dérive climatique
est quelque chose qui est aujourd'hui
inscrite dans la physx terre qu'on ne
peut plus l'arrêter
il faut attendre plus de dix mille ans
pour épurer un surplus de co2 une fois
qu'on l'a mis dans l'atmosphère
il faut attendre plusieurs milliers
d'années avant que la cryosphère sert
les calottes glaciaires et fini de
réagir un surplus de co2 tomber dans
l'atmosphère et donc que l'océan est
fini de
j'ai donc en fait la dérive climatiques
qu'on a mise en route elle est là elle
va durer jusqu'à la fin des temps
historiques le climat de l'an 2020 il
est on sait qu'il est déjà perdue il
reviendra jamais il va il va partir il
reviendra jamais donc le on est dans un
processus qui est très très long et très
très lent mais par ailleurs on sait déjà
que les gens qui aujourd'hui ont
l'espoir est encore en vie en 20 ans de
toute façon eux-mêmes avec leur propre
corps vont voir les conséquences de la
dérive qui s'en soucie je veux dire moi
aujourd'hui je vois des choses que je
voyais pas hier un temps précis dans 20
ans je suis toujours vivant je verrai
des choses que je ne vois pas
aujourd'hui
donc certes on vit un peu au crédit nos
descendants
mais quelque part nous y est même au
crédit de nous mêmes aujourd'hui par
contre ce qui est très difficile dans
cette affaire c'est que avec le temps de
résidence du co2 dans l'atmosphère donc
ils se comptent en siècle en millénaires
le lieu d émission n'a pas d'importance
en ce qui concerne des conséquences
sérieuses qui le climat de la france
dans 20 ans n'est pas le résultat des
émissions de la france sur les 20 ans
qui viennent
c'est le résultat des émissions
planétaires sur les 20 ans qui viennent
qui le dire comme les émissions
planétaires ne dépendent pas que de nous
ça veut dire que même si chacun fait sa
parfums commandes il ya une espèce de
jeu du passager clandestin dans cette
histoire où le fait de faire sa part ne
vous garantit même pas contre le fait
que ça va stabiliser la situation
donc c'est compliqué par contre on ne
peut évidemment pas imaginer que la
situation soit stabilisée sans que
chacun fasse sa part donc il ya un jeu
compliqué dans cette histoire
et comme les états sont souverains
compliqué sauf si vous envahissez les
autres avec des chars et des avions
enfin le moment ça marche pas trop bas
on n'imagine surtout pas le faire pour
les émissions de co2 aujourd'hui et même
pour autre chose ça pas très bien marché
pour autre chose c'est compliqué quand
on essaye d'envahir la russie l'histoire
montre que ça se passe pas toujours très
bien j'ai succès n'est pas garanti
puis aujourd'hui je sais pas s'il ya
beaucoup de gens qui ont envie d'envahir
la chine
peut-être peut-être ça poserait aussi
quelques petits problèmes militaires et
logistiques donc le on est obligé de
repasser par la coopération
internationale mais on est aussi obligé
d'en passer par l'action domestique on
est obligé d'en passer par l'action à
long terme comme on est obligé d'en
passer par l'absence de procrastination
et de commencer à s'y mettre demain
matin donc c'est un problème qui est
particulièrement ardue parce que il faut
faire feu de tout bois c'est qu'ils me
permettre et avenir à tous les échelons
simultanément leurs parmi ceux qui sont
engagés sur ces observateurs est engagé
sur ces questions vous avez une vue sur
les questions nucléaires qui diffère un
peu de beaucoup de vos camarades et vous
êtes plutôt critiques des partis
écologistes sur la question nucléaire
alors je réussis à me faire des amis
partout je réussis à faire des ennemis
chez les écologistes sur la question du
nucléaire mais je réussis à me faire des
ennemis afin de moins en moins dans le
monde économique sur la question de la
croissance
je réussis à me faire en voilà donc
c'est un procès un prime qui traite
disruptif parce qu'en fait ils obligent
à revoir totalement l'ordre des
priorités et d'ailleurs ainsi les
risques
alors en ce qui concerne le nucléaire
civil
voici sur le fait que celle du nucléaire
civil dont je parle
alors j'aime l'analyse de la situation
que je fais c'est que les risques portés
par le nucléaire civil sont
considérablement inférieur aux risques
qu'il permet d'éviter quand on le met en
avant donc c'est un arbitrage des
risques vous savez c'est comme les
effets secondaires des médicaments
il ya tout un tas de médicaments qui ont
des effets secondaires ça vous donne des
boutons des palpitations les poils dans
le nez j'ai pas quoi mais si vous ne
prenez pas vous risquez de mourir va en
général les gens le prennent
bon ben là c'est exactement pareil le
nucléaire risque de nous donner les
poils donné ok très bien mais si on s'en
sert moins on va a chuté plus durement
comment vous expliquez et du coup le
fait que le mantra de tous les partis
écologistes quels qu'ils soient qui sont
donc fondés pour préserver le climat y
est quand même ce tabou du nucléaire
s'est fait partie quand même n'a reçu
est ce que c'est parce que il ya aussi
rien que nucléaire militaire est ce que
c'est le péché originel de l'allemagne
et que les verts allemands ont un peu
influencer le reste des verts européens
ont là dedans je ne peux me livrer à des
conjectures parce que c'est compliqué de
faire des démonstrations mathématiques
mais dans les hypothèses que j'ai sur la
table il y en a eu effectivement qui est
que en allemagne les grünen ont été très
focalisé sur la question du nucléaire
militaire
j'imagine pour des questions
d'humiliation c'est à dire que c'est la
puissance qui vous a vaincu pendant la
guerre installe des têtes nucléaires
survient ils sont aussi nés dans les
années 80 dans les faits les robes ici
lorsque rigal parler de guerre nucléaire
limitée en europe alors j'allais y venir
c'est à dire que et en plus contre leurs
frères
c'est à dire que l'on met en allemagne
de l'ouest des têtes nucléaires qui
peuvent éventuellement aller zigouiller
leurs frères qui sont en allemagne de
l'est
j'imagine que ça n'a pas dû la faire
très plaisir et que ça a nourri un
ressentiment contre le nucléaire
militaire qui ensuite a dérivé sur le
nucléaire civil
en ce qui concerne l'appui en plus
d'aucun message et pas la moindre preuve
explique que tout ça a été abondamment
financé par les russes qu'il y avait
évidemment intérêt parce qu'avoir des
antinucléaires s'étaient nécessairement
affaibli hier entre guillemets l'ennemi
greenpeace est né avec une opposition au
nucléaire militaire
et quand ils ont fini par le point par
obtenir eux en particulier mais quand on
a un il ya eu la fin des essais
nucléaires militaires
enfin la fin des essais réels j'ai envie
de dire eh bien
le combat le plus propre ce qui leur a
semblé qu'on va plus proches c'était une
guerre civile
en ce moment ils sont pas dit tiens
reconversion on va on va se reconvertir
dans le climat et du coup on va être
pour les nucléaire civil ils n'ont pas
fait ça il
je pense qu'il ya un autre élément qui
joue de manière forte c'est que le
mouvement écologiste historique est un
mouvement qui emprunte aussi pour partie
aux listes c'est à dire qu'il ya un
mouvement anti machine anti techno dans
le mouvement historique écologistes pas
à tort toujours et comme le nucléaire
fait partie de la technique
je pense qu'ils passent dans la barque
et quand vous regardez les sondages
d'opinion en france en tout cas je pense
que c'est ça explique pourquoi les gens
qui sont les plus climato sceptiques
sont aussi les plus pros du clae air et
inversement
je pense qu'il ya des climato sceptiques
sont des gens qui pensent que la
technique peut pas faire de mal
et si il aime bien la technique du coup
il aime bien le nucléaire et inversement
les gens qui sont soucieux de
l'environnement pense qu'on a déjà trop
de technique qui d'une manière générale
mange trop de ressources et fait trop de
mal à l'environnement et le nucléaire en
étant une parmi d'autres
du coup ça passe dans la barque je
soupçonne que c'est là alors il ya quand
même un petit bémol à cette explication
qui est que à ce moment il devrait aussi
être complété au yen industriels etc
voilà donc on explication est pas
totalement satisfaisante et re sujet qui
divise la semaine j'ai est ce que vous y
voyez plutôt quelque chose qui permettra
de lutter contre la chambre climatique
ou quelque chose qui va aggraver et là
on entend un peu l'élan à la la c'est
très clair ça va l'aggraver la singer
participe de la fascination du gadget
pour moi je suis assez critique contre
la 5g et je pense que dans le contexte
actuel on a d'autres chats à fouetter
que de pouvoir regarder de la vidéo
définition qui sont sur deux écrans que
ce n'est pas fait pour ça quand on est
dans le métro le bus est essentiellement
un sac ça va servir aux drones et
socialement 4 dans les ascenseurs 80% du
trafic internet aujourd'hui c'est de la
vidéo c'est de l'image animée 80% dans
lequel vous avez en gros 4 car un quart
de vidéo à la demande netflix et
consorts un quart de porno un quart de
youtube et un quart de votre cousine qui
vous envoie la vidéo du petit dernier
qui vient de faire ses dents ou la vidéo
du chat du voisin qui ces prix là que
dans le portail bon voilà c'est ça le
dernier quart est-ce que c'est d'une
urgence absolue dans le contexte dans
lequel nous sommes que tout ça soit
envoyé en plus haute définition
encore une fois sur des écrans qui pour
l'essentiel du temps ne sont pas faits
pour sa part complètement persuadés et
les gens qui ont entre guillemets
intérêt au crime se retranche derrière
le fait qu' on va pouvoir opérer les
petites vieilles dans la creuse
en fait il faut pas juste un réseau pour
repérer dans la creuse à distance il
faut aussi un bloc à distance pour faire
pour moi et puis c'est beaucoup moins
cher de louer un taxi est d'amener la
personne en question dans un hôpital en
ville que d'installer la 5g rien pour
opérer des gens de temps en temps donc
le don quoi moi pour moi on est vraiment
dans la fascination du gadget ou on
réfléchit même pas on est dans cette
danse est dans ce paradigme du monde
infini où on se dit on va régler avec
quand même des forces trafic d'influencé
quand même l'ensemble des boîtes de
communication qu'ils sont cons des
budgets conséquents pour vous faire
parler en faveur de cela et c'est quand
même assez impressionnant
oui alors qu'ils qui a intérêt au crime
l'état pour commencer parce qu'il va
vendre les fréquences et qu'en ce moment
il est ça va lui faire un peu d'argent
ouais fait partout où il peut avoir un
peu d'argent il est pour ensuite vous
avez des équipementiers qui pousse au
crime
en soit voilà donc les fabricants
smartphones et les fabricants
d'équipements pour réseaux les
opérateurs sont plus divisés en
particulier les petits parce qu'ils
savent très bien que ils vont devoir
investir massivement dans le réseau
alors qu'ils seront pas payés en retour
sur le montant des abonnements qui va
pas pouvoir augmenter autant que voilà
il ya eu une tribune de martin bruit
avant le 2 avant le kickoff le lancement
officiel du déploiement disons qu'il
était urgent d'attendre sur la 5g et les
consommateurs sont évidemment pour parce
que le téléphone est devenu un objet
statut social et que ces voix là à tapas
le truc singer terrain car il qu'elles
ont rien vous jeter sur la convention
citoyenne est ce que c'est par un gadget
ou quelque chose qui a été utile aussi
bien retomber un peu pour le débat ou
même on ne m'apporte d'idées je pense
que ça a été à la fois utile et
frustrant ça a été utile parce que ça ça
ça va être ça apporter la preuve dans un
certain nombre de domaines de choses qui
avant n'était n'était pas prouvée et là
est la preuve la plus intéressante pour
moi que ça a porté ses que vous prenez
150 personnes tirées au sort et vous
leur donner de l'information sur le
problème à traiter et le temps d'en
discuter et vous en faites une bande
d'écolos donc ça je trouve que c'est une
information extrêmement intéressante et
je rapproche d'un sondage qui vient
d'être publiée par les échos il ya pas
longtemps où il ya trois quarts des
français qui disent on est conscient du
fait qu'on va devoir changer nos modes
de vie mais pas tout de suite et le pas
tout de suite pour moi il se rapproche
du fait que c'est beaucoup plus facile
de faire tout de suite quand on est dans
une action collective que quand on est
dans une action individuelle vous êtes
entraîné qu'à la force du groupe et que
vous vous marginalisez pas socialement
en fait ce qui est très difficile dans
le changement d'habitude c'est la
marginalisation sociale qui va avec
alors vous allez commencer à vous
chicaner avec vos enfants votre conjoint
vos voisins vos collègues sais pas quoi
si vous commencez à faire autre chose
que ce que vous faisiez avant si tout le
monde c'est autre chose en même temps ce
problème là cesse d'exister et on est
quand même des animaux grier on a besoin
d'être en harmonie
avec notre sphère sociale c'est un truc
fondamental pour nous donc le cas montré
la convention citoyenne c'est que si les
gens bougent en même temps ils sont
prêts à bouger de façon beaucoup plus
significative que voilà ça c'est
l'enseignement général
après si on prend les mesures dans le
détail il y en a certaines pour
lesquelles je me dis oui bon ça c'est un
peu anecdotique ou c'est pas
nécessairement le coeur du problème
d'autres qui manque peut-être peu
importe il avait fui week-end ils sont
partis de zéro donc faut pas leur
demander la lune
donc ça c'était le côté très positif
le côté très frustrant c'est que je
pense que le gouvernement a géré ça en
dilettante parce que c'était un truc par
mylène dans tous les ballons d'essai que
lens mâcon et en particulier il l'a
gérée en dilettante sur deux points il
n'a pas vu le sujet très technique qui
va avec
parce que parler le carbone c'est comme
parler argent faut tout compte est
partout tout le temps en carbone donc à
ce moment il faut des gens qui savent
qu'ils savent faire
il faut le temps de le faire donc il
aurait fallu doter la convention
citoyenne d'une force d'une force de
frappe interne tard bureau conseil
albert laginha secrète rien une forme de
secrétariat technique qui à chaque fois
que la convention réfléchissions
recherche un peu oui m'aurait dit abbas
a zappé ce temps d'accord vous envisagé
d'interdire la pub pour les 4,4 je vais
vous faire un calcul de coin table et je
vais vous dire bah ça a priori c'est
susceptible d'éviter tant en termes
d'émissions ou de s'inscrire dans une
mesure qui pourrait éviter temps donc il
leur aurait fallu ça parce que comme ça
il aurait pu jouer aux lego et empilées
jusqu'au moment où il arrivait aux 40%
qui étaient dans leur mandat est
symétriquement en face quand la crau a
dit j'en prendrais tout sans filtre
c'était une connerie parce que ce qu'il
fallait qu'ils disent c'était pas je
reprendrai tout sans filtre c'était je
m'engage à tout faire évaluer
sérieusement j'espère qu'il aurait dû
dire donc en rouge vous traitent comme
des interlocuteurs sérieux mais pas
nécessairement en m'ayant donné la
vérité divine parce que vous pouvez vous
aussi vous trompez sedera avoir un enfer
pavé de bonnes intentions
donc l'engagement que je prends ces
beaux considérés comme des gens sérieux
et de discuter sérieusement avec vous et
ça ça veut dire que je vous met des
moyens en face donc c'était ça la
frustration c'est qu'il n'y a pas eu ce
dialogue technique et quantifier et pour
avoir discuté avec quelques personnes
qui faisaient partie de la convention
parfaitement conscient et c'est aussi un
élément de frustration de leur côté et
je pense qu'aujourd'hui le sentiment un
peu énervé que certains peuvent avoir
vient plus du fait qu'on les a pas
traités comme des interlocuteurs sérieux
à cause du processus qui est je prends
je prends pas de manière discrétionnaire
à 110 chevaux je prends mouvement
passage strange
c'est à une manière de faire ça la bonne
manière de faire c'est tout faire
évaluer de regarder toutes les
contreparties et de regarder à l'arrivée
ce comprends et je comprends pas dans un
discours articulé et cohérent et c'est
pas ça qui est c'est pas ça qu'il ya eu
du bon alors je ne sais pas si les
députés pour moi un peu redressé
injustement la loi climat qui va ramener
29 mars
je ne sais pas si les députés pour
redresser la barre parce qu'ils n'auront
pas plus que le gouvernement la task
force technique pour faire cette
évaluation quantitative à la volée sur
la totalité des articles et la totalité
des quelques milliers d'amendements qui
sont déposées en ce moment le chili
project on a déposé quelques uns des
amendements pharma proposer plus
exactement un certain nombre qui ont été
repris par un certain nombre de députés
dans les amendements qu'on propose par
exemple il ya étendre la garantie légale
des objets de telle sorte que la
rotation des parcs soient ralentis parce
que fabriquer un ordinateur fabriqué une
voiture fabriquée un fauteuil tout ça ça
consomme de l'énergie aie ça émet des
gaz à effet de serre donc si vous
augmentez la garantie légale à une
partie des voulés truc tombereaux - en
panne ou si ça tombe en panne on vous le
remplace le fabricant france qu'il faut
pour sa peau - en panne sur un mode
obsolescence programmée et donc ça fera
des émissions évitées pardon donc le mât
typiquement cet amendement que le site
project a proposé vous avez évalué les
députés ils n'auront pas les moyens à la
volée ouais d'évaluer ce qui va avec
voilà vous ai eu les moyens de le faire
non même pas parce que ça va trop vite
un débat parlementaire pour m'emmener
les moyens de faire ça on aurait pu
faire un calcul de coin table mais pas
un n'a pas on n'a pas le temps voilà
donc c'est ça le drame c'est que on a un
objectif on a on a une obligation de
résultat sur les émissions puisque
l'atmosphère se fiche de tout état d'âme
et tout ce qu'elle voit c'est la
quantité globale démission qui arrive
alors qu'en face il n'y a pas les moyens
de traiter ça comme une obligation de
résultat et on continue à se contenter
de slogans ou de déclaration de principe
qui malheureusement sont pas suffisantes
pour aller jusqu'au bout on arrive
malheureusement à la fin de cet
entretien quels sont selon vous les les
énergies nouvelles qui ne sont pas
suffisamment exploité qui pourrait
apporter un début de réponse à tous ces
défis alors l'énergie en physique elle a
une définition assez précises c'est ce
qui quantifie le changement d'état d'un
système et quand on parle d'une erreur
d'une énergie en fait on parle d'une
interaction comme ça qu'on dit en
physique qui est susceptible de
provoquer un changement qui libèrent de
l'énergie alors une interaction c'est
par exemple la traction universelle
c'est susceptible de provoquer un
changement et la chute d'un corps dans
le champ gravitationnel terrestre par
exemple une masse d'eau qui descendent
le long d'une conduite forcée pour aller
alimenter une turbine je suis d'accord
et ça vous permet de libérer de
l'énergie la combustion
c'est une interaction qui provient de la
force du réarrangement des atomes
quand vous passez par exemple du carbone
et d'hydrogène à du co2 et de la vapeur
d'eau et ça libère de l'énergie à cause
du réarrangement des couches
électroniques la fission c'est un
réarrangement de nucléons dans le noyau
et ça vient de l'interaction une
interaction forte et ça vous libèrent de
l'énergie donc pour trouver une nouvelle
source d'énergie faut inventer une
nouvelle interaction faut vous plaît
clamant faut pas inventer il faut la
découvrir dans leur action ils sont ce
qu'elles sont peu compter dessus
moi qui comptent pas trop parce que
complètement sûr que ça arrive après on
peut donc essayer de se servir de celle
qu'on a déjà
et dans celles qu'on a déjà on a les
énergies carbonées les énergies non
carbonées ans les énergies carbonées
c'est tout ce qu'ils oxydation du
carbone donc c'est la combustion des
combustibles fossiles ou c'est la
combustion du bois au delà de son seuil
de renouvellement comme ça c'est dans
les énergies carbonées c'est celle là
quand il faut se débarrasser dans les
énergies non carbonées vous avez deux
familles vous avez le nucléaire et va
formuler nucléaire plus exactement
donc largement nucléaire et les énergies
renouvelables les énergies renouvelables
vous avez plein plein de trucs parce que
vous avez de la chaleur et de la chute
l'eau c'est la force mécanique levant
enfin bon bref vous avez plein de trucs
qui tournait vous avez au rayonnement
électromagnétique le soleil tout n'est
pas égale à tous les énergies
renouvelables il faut bien voir que
c'est celle dont on sort l'humanité a
été totalement renouvelable jusqu'à il
ya deux siècles et on a à ce moment là
on n'avait pas de civilisation
industrielle
donc l'idée qu'on va pouvoir revenir à
une civilisation industrielle avec juste
des énergies renouvelables pas le temps
de développer aujourd'hui mais moi je
n'y crois pas non seulement j'y crois
pas mais je prêt à parier mon argent sur
le fait que ça n'arrivera pas donc on va
devoir faire avec une combinaison de
sobriété
ça veut dire moins et d'énergies
renouvelables et de nucléaire les
énergies renouvelables sont
particulièrement commode à mettre en
oeuvre parce qu'elles sont très diffus
us quand vous avez beaucoup d espace
donc les énergies renouvelables en suède
10 millions de personnes pour les deux
tiers de la superficie française ça
passe les énergies renouvelables en dans
certains pays d'afrique vous avez des
grands fleuves sur lesquels on peut
mettre des barrages tout pas totalement
anodin pour l'environnement sur l'it en
passant avec une population qui
aujourd'hui consomme pas beaucoup
d'électricité
ça passe par contre les énergies
renouvelables en europe vous avez
essentiellement des pays plat et
densément peuplées ça passera pas enfin
pour l'essentiel de l'europe
continentale
donc la marche d'adaptation c'est le
nucléaire et c'est pour ça que je dis
que en fait on va devoir faire une
combinatoire entre le nucléaire et la
sobriété moi enfin nucléaire plus en
face aux grilles étaient gros comme ça
que ça va se passer
merci beaucoup jean marc jancovici merci
pour cet entretien passionnant